welcome to this video against harmful 13
okay let's see what I can do here you're
going to play a quince jam bed ok I have
played him in earlier sessions remember
that with a couple of wins so I can't be
6 it's an interesting line actually it's
not very popular but not bad so it's
surprising i was thinking the Queen
cheeks maybe ok let's just centralized
here and see if I can maybe get ok there
are no tricks here Bishop a 6 or
something it's not working ok here we
try to provoke weaknesses cm and really
I cannot take on age 6 come on i can
take on age 6 year but g6 was the only
move I think was he kind of saving
himself I don't see how maybe he can
play at five takes Queen takes f5
but if if he takes I have Queen f5 which
is interesting and probably just better
threatening queen age 7 and made and I
think this is winning h6 is really a
strange move as Bishop takes h6 is very
very obvious actually yeah takes Queen
f5 that's better than queen age 6 g6
Bishop takes 36 and I'm threatening
Bishop takes 27 so let's say you go see
for i will take g7 and that's it
yeah now he's starting to think it's a
bit late okay yeah so let's just check
it briefly but this is this is important
Queen age six f5 maybe he's surviving
and that one is not born that the bishop
is only seven blocking a flight square
so ruki a tweener schleck resigns this
is check checkmate the head does not
have that flight square yeah sometimes
you should really just threaten
checkmate with Queen h5 yes to play g6
and this is normal I say I think just a
normal position going back I what you're
thinking provoke this little move here
maybe it's a weakness and this is a
normal position i think that spread out
winning o Queen f5 is also strong I
didn't think about that one that that's
maybe even stronger g6 and I takes 26
now it's all completely killing yeah he
just has to go g6 him maybe you wanted
to avoid this with a draw but well not
doing that mine 86 is just flat-out
losing Queen fi this maybe maybe even
even even quicker but I don't see how he
avoids defeat IAM cheeks takes f5 yeah
it can go f5 that that's possible for
continuing for a moment here rook & e6
and wins the rook yeah okay that was a
it was a quick one thanks for watching